como professor eu sempre tive um sonho e
esse sonho não era um sonho pequeno
simplesmente mudar o mundo
os professores também têm esse sonho
parece uma besteira mas nós como os
professores a gente que é realmente
fazer isso o que precisa é necessário eu
imaginava e no início da carreira quando
é recente forma a gente tem entusiasmo
muito entusiasmo e eu imaginava também
que olhando professores mas em final de
carreira que esse entusiasmo e ele iria
diminuindo com o passar do tempo esse
entusiasmo que a gente tinha no início
da carreira eu como professor de física
até fiz um gráfico para mostrar como eu
imaginava que o entusiasmo da até
aposentadoria iria acontecer em chegar
numa aposentadoria
o entusiasmo mesmo que eu imaginava
minha decepção o meu entusiasmo em 2005
foi praticamente a zero
aconteceram coisas na minha vida perdi o
emprego perdia namorada quebrei minha
vida um pouco traumática porque o que
acontece
existe um sistema que é o sistema
sistema é são os pais a comunidade sofre
decepcionar
em 2005 eu tomei uma decisão não vou ser
mais professor professor porque eu não
queria ser um velho frustrado
eu me imaginei aquele velho coisas e
pensem comigo frustrado não quero isso
para a minha vida então eu pensei comigo
com trocar de posição
montei a ser vestibulando na
tive que estudar biologia tudo de novo
já tinha mudado olha passei em direito
sou graduado em direito entre em 2007
achei que com direito a uma ferramenta
poderosa entrar na magistratura
pensei comigo não agora eu vou fazer
grandes mudanças eu me formei em 2012
entre 2007 foi em 2012 o que aconteceu
fui procurar um escritório foi fazer um
concurso não eu acabei nessa época
sabendo de um tal de youtube que já
existia desde 2005 era tão famoso na
época mas existe um tal de outubro os
alunos presenciais e esses alunos alguns
marcava uma aula ao sábado e alguns
alunos não podiam freqüentar ao sábado e
o que eu fiz eu pensei comigo não eu
na época o iphone da época
o nokia n95 com recursos avançados disse
hoje em dia é um suporte para celular
na época não tinha na época tinha claro
de câmera não tinha gambiarra tinha
entrada do fone de ouvido lateral
entrada lateral e um suporte chegava eu
na aula de sábado com o meu tripé minha
câmera ficava meio cinza estava para
gravar do jeito que sair e aí nasceram
as minhas primeiras vídeo aulas lá em
vou postar mandar por e mail ou não o
posto de youtube o que acontece em 2009
em que nessa época conturbada meu
entusiasmo tinha ido a 0 nesse meio
tempo também já estava começando a
gravar as vídeo aulas e essas vídeo
aulas começaram a fazer o meu entusiasmo
voltar
observe que o entusiasmo
já passou 100 por cento atualmente
depois 2016/17 o entusiasmo não tem
limite para na não tá crescendo
exponencialmente
aí começou nascimento então do meu canal
do youtube
observem a qualidade primorosa da imagem
isso aí em 2009 antecipando a moda
barbuda pessoal
copiando essa moda de barulho lá
barbudão casaco de inverno
o quadro uma maravilha enxergar tudo a
qualidade sonora vocês não imaginam o
que é a qualidade sonora incrível
e aí depois disso recebendo vários
depoimentos dos alunos dizendo me
ajudando não é só com os seus alunos de
são paulo
aprendendo física contigo e tem algo
grande algo muito grande
não posso fazer
peguei do meu bolso investir em câmera
microfone
hoje em dia nem precisa hoje em dia a
tecnologia não precisa de toda essa
qualidade porque hoje em dia um celular
um iphone já tem grande qualidade de
áudio e imagem na época comprei uma
câmera tripé
achei muito legal
fui pesquisar como é que se fazia isso
a edição de vídeo
tudo o que aprendeu no próprio youtube
como editar vídeo como editar áudio eu
vi que podia tirar aquele ruído do fundo
expandir na verdade a esses interesses
comecei a me interessar e comecei a
produzir vídeo aulas mas é daquelas
vídeo-aulas jogadas assim sem nenhuma
ordem
não vou organizar vou fazer um curso de
física desde a aula um o que é física a
um número
depois eu vou gravar a sequência pegar
um livro didático tópico por tópico e eu
vou gravar um curso completo desde o que
é física até física moderna passando por
tecnologia ondas tudo então qualquer
pessoa que esteja lá no ensino médio
vestibular o aluno que aprender física
porque aprender física existem essas
pessoas existem querem aprender física
querem mostrar exemplo para vocês
então resolvi fazer um curso completo
achava vai dar umas em 200
o curso tem mais de 500 vídeo aulas no
youtube
todas gratuitas nesse meio tempo eo
youtube viu que esse mercado para eles é
um mercado para nós eu não encaro assim
eu encaro como uma missão encaro como a
realização do meu sonho
o youtube vídeos no youtube e resolveram
investir dentro do youtube assim como
tem um espaço para gamers também tem um
espaço para educadores que o youtube e
bhutta então tem os you tube e eles
chamam os professores de edu dracena
assim christian e desde 11 de julho de
2014 eu faço parte desde o lançamento
dessa plataforma dentro da plataforma
que seria uma parte do youtube reservada
professores então em 26 de novembro de
2015 comecei em 2012 então gravei a
última aula aula 501 alguns que têm
toque deve perguntar puxa porque esse
500 quinhentas e uma aula então aulas é
muito mais do que eu previa o previ uma
sem aulas entre 10 e 40 minutos
o mau tempo que eu me dediquei
dois dias por semana dedicadas às aulas
no youtube ok
hoje eu sou o canal com maior número de
visualizações independente que tem a
mais que têm todas as disciplinas de
física o maior número de visualizações
física fabris
então eu tenho atualmente de quase 16
milhões de visualizações 209 mil
inscritos que são os assinantes
aquele sonho de mudar o mundo
aquele sonho de mudar o mundo ele
começou a se concretizar com as aulas do
youtube
e quando falo conquistar o mundo é
realmente conquistar o mundo porque o
youtube ele fornece no google analytics
do youtube
os locais em que a gente é visualizado o
trabalho de passar o mouse por todos os
países do mundo onde tinha visualização
eu fiquei sabendo
obviamente países brasil mais acessados
obviamente e países de língua portuguesa
agora ilhas fiji sete minutos e fiquei
pensando agora apenas cinco países
eu não a índia o paquistão e coreia do
norte
uma estudada na linguagem do papua nova
guiné para ver se eu consigo atingir
esses caras né
de alguma maneira chegar lá uma
brincadeira mas a ideia pessoal de
conquistar o mundo como professor de
sonhar grande ela partir daí a história
da dona maria josé que veio me visitar
75 anos estava estudando física porque
ela custava de física
obviamente a aposentada e ela queria
aprender física e ela ela vem com uma
tremenda dizendo que ela queria
agradecer à minha mãe por ter me botar
no mundo disse
que coisa mais fofa que coisa mais fofa
física porque ela queria aprender
também mora ele mora meio mal na ilha de
açores e assistir às aulas porque ele
queria também os 60 anos que aprender
física então ele queria aprender física
porque ele gostava de física não precisa
fazer
a maioria dos meus alunos são
vestibulandos e alunos de ensino médio
mas também tem um eu tenho um aluno que
aprende física porque ele quer aprender
física e aí onde é que ele vai aprender
às vezes não quer tem vergonha internet
ele aprende tudo do zero desde o que é
física até física moderna alunos de
angola muitos alunos de angola à luz de
angola me impressiona porque os alunos
de angola às vezes não vou procurar a
cidade ao sul da cidade tal e se até do
litoral mas alguns alunos
eu vou procurar e eu vejo que não tem
cidade ao redor
eu fico pensando poxa que realmente aí
que estou conseguindo realizar o meu
sonho de mudar o mundo e se realmente
foi marcante cheguei a me arrepiar agora
e sempre que eu penso na história do max
e emme choque ele mostra que é pra isso
que eu sou professor
o max é um aluno que era um aluno pobre
um aluno que não tinha condições de
estudar ele achou materiais no lixo e eu
sonho dele era ser engenheiro
eletricista então estudava na biblioteca
pública e eu consegui ajudá lo a
conquistar esse sonho então para isso é
esse o max para mim é referência nesse
meu projeto e para terminar a pergunta e
você porque muitos professores pensam na
dificuldade mas como é que eu vou gravar
só a primeira bola que eu gravava as 10
horas e as aulas para destravar hoje em
dia depois começa a destravar já começa
a olhar dentro da câmera
o mesmo quadro então já começa a ter uma
interação tu já faz a pegadinha
espero responder e tudo começa
time da câmera mas vai aprender na
prática e hoje em dia que ele pega pega
o telefone e liga ele o microfone que
vem é de altíssima qualidade
o teu android é se não sei que é de
altíssima qualidade vai gravar uma vídeo
aula hoje em dia daquela qualidade e
agora já vai já vai começar top entendi
então eu te pergunto o que vai fazer
para mudar o mundo
obrigado
[Aplausos]